- Good morning.
I hope you're having an amazing day.
It's Mark Wiens.
I'm in Trat, Thailand.
This is day six of our
eastern provinces of Thailand
food and culture and travel tour.
Today, we are spending
the day at Ban Nam Chiao.
And so, I'm really looking forward to it.
I know the village.
The community is very picturesque,
and we're gonna do some cooking.
We're gonna eat, of course.
I'm gonna take you on a tour
and walk you around the community
where we're gonna be
cooking some halal food
and we're gonna get some fish.
I'm not sure all that we're gonna cook,
but I'm gonna share it all with
you in this video right now.
(upbeat music)
(speaking in foreign language)
This market is very small.
Very, very, small.
There's only like, one
row of vendors right here,
and there happens to be no fish today,
so maybe the fishing
boats haven't arrived.
(speaking in foreign language)
(upbeat music)
We ended up having to
drive back into Trat town
to go to the market
because there's no fish.
She was saying that for some reason,
the fish vendors never came.
So, it's just a 10-kilometer
drive to get here.
We're at the market,
where we were yesterday,
but this is the central
market of Trat town.
We're gonna buy some ingredients here.
(motorbike motor humming)
(speaking in foreign language)
Since we're at the big market,
we've asked Auntie to make
a couple of specific dishes.
Well, I'm not totally sure of the dishes,
but a couple of dishes using rakam,
which is the fruit that she's
just buying, which is a...
(stammering) In English,
I mean, there's two types.
There's the salacca,
and there's the rakam.
Well, the rakam is in Thai.
(stammering) They're a
little bit different.
One is, rakam is a little
fatter but it's a sour fruit.
She's gonna make some dishes with that.
And I also want to try to search out
probably what is my
favorite single ingredient
in this region of Thailand.
(speaking in foreign language)
We just found the ingredient.
It's called krawan in Thai.
It is cardamom stems.
It's an amazing ingredient.
(motorbike motor humming)
(speaking in foreign language)
(loud scraping)
We got all the ingredients.
(motorbike motor humming)
I'm very excited for the
dishes that she's gonna make.
(upbeat music)
We made it back to Ban Nam Chiao.
This is the community.
We're walking to Kunnal's house,
and I think we're coming up
on the river right now, too.
We have made it to the
picturesque Ban Nam Chiao.
It's along the river.
There are big fishing boats,
but the main icon of this
community is the bridge,
and what an impressively
steep bridge this is
that goes over the water,
and it's so steep because of the boats,
so the boats can pass through.
(footsteps echoing)
(upbeat music)
The railing is a little low.
It's kind of high up here,
but this is beautiful.
Oh, this is gorgeous.
The big fishing boats.
There is one of the main
mosques of the village.
It's such a gorgeous little community.
Wow, you wouldn't want these wooden planks
to break on you now, though.
(upbeat music)
This is kind of the community
center area right here,
and this is where we're
gonna do the cooking.
They also offer eco-tourism
activities here.
Most of the houses in this community
are on stilts above the water.
And it's a fishing community.
There's big fishing
boats, there's mangroves.
They're doing all of the cooking in here,
and we have just this sleepy,
fisherman village view.
(skin loudly snapping off)
This is the krawan.
It has a very smooth texture,
but yeah, they look like shoots,
the shoots of the cardamom,
or cardamom stems.
This really is one of the
kings of the ingredients
of Trat and this entire
eastern region of Thailand.
(pestle loudly pounding)
(speaking in foreign language)
She's gonna add the krawan to two dishes.
One is the tom sum, which is the soup,
and then she's also gonna
make a stir-fry with gai ban,
which is a village free-range chicken
stir-fried with curry
paste, and also krawan.
(speaking in foreign language)
Some of the rakam, that snake fruit,
is also gonna go into the soup,
but another dish that I am
most looking forward to trying
is she's gonna make a
fried fish with a nam prik
dipping chili sauce using
shrimp paste as well as rakam.
(speaking in foreign language)
She massaged the fruit with her hands,
kind of squeezing out all that juice,
and then she dropped it into the soup.
And immediately, as
that hit that hot water,
you can smell how sour the steam is.
The fish goes in, and
at this point, again,
like normal Thai cooking style,
you do not want to stir it
because that will make the
fish a bad smell and taste,
so it's just gonna boil.
Oh man, the aroma of that fruit
though, it smells amazing.
(upbeat music)
(oil sizzling)
Okay, next, she's gonna fry the fish.
(upbeat music)
(oil sizzling)
(speaking in foreign language)
Oh, she's also gonna make
stir-fried noodles with that crab,
Trat-style.
(speaking in foreign language)
These noodles are known to be very sweet.
So, she added in quite
a lot of palm sugar,
and she's like, boiling that down
into a syrup for the noodles.
(oil sizzling)
(speaking in foreign language)
(laughing)
It's quite a complexity of ingredients
that she added to the noodles.
She first started with
the sugar, the palm sugar.
Then, she added in coconut
milk, a lot of coconut milk,
and simmered that down.
Then, she added in some
chili paste, curry paste,
and she added in some
tamarind, sour tamarind,
so that's gonna be sweet and sour,
and then she's gonna add in the crab.
Oh, she added in all the noodles,
which is woon sen, which
are mung bean noodles.
And then, she's gonna add in the crab.
(pestle loudly pounding)
(plastic bag crinkling)
(upbeat music)
(speaking in foreign language)
Here's where things get exciting.
Often times across Thailand though,
you use lime juice to make it sour.
But she's making the version with rakam,
that same fruit, the snake
fruit, to add the sourness.
Oh, that's a combination
I've never had before.
(motorboat motor humming)
(pestle loudly pounding)
And now, on to the final dish.
She's making the stir-fried
chicken with the krawan,
with the cardamom stems,
but she's also making,
wholly from scratch, the curry paste.
So, she's pounding up some garlic.
She's pounding up some chilis.
She tossed in some krachai in
there, which is finger root,
kind of similar to ginger.
(oil loudly sizzling)
(speaking in foreign language)
Oh, it's so good.
Oh, that shrimp paste is so fragrant.
And you've got the sourness of the fruit.
(speaking in foreign language)
Wow.
(toddler cooing)
(speaking in foreign language)
So, she said we should begin
with the stir-friend noodles,
because then it will get
kind of mushy and dry.
But these noodles, man,
she added so much coconut milk in it,
and then it just soaked
up into these noodles.
And yeah, for sure, they're
gonna be quite sweet as well.
(speaking in foreign language)
(toddler cooing)
Mmm!
Mmm.
Oh, so good.
I mean, it is sweet, but it's so good.
Oh, it's so rich and sticky
from that coconut milk.
Mmm!
And it has that balance of sour flavor
from the sour tamarind.
Wow.
Wow, I mean, that's amazing.
This one is the soup.
This one is with fish, with rakam as well.
It's a tom sum soup.
And, oh, she added in the krawan as well,
the cardamom shoots, the cardamom stems.
So, I'm gonna take some of the fish.
I'll put this,
actually, let me just taste that broth,
but with some of the, a little
bit of everything in there.
Oh!
Oh, that's so pure.
It's so nice and sour.
It has like, that acidic sourness
coming from that snakefruit.
And then, that krawan, I love it.
It's like lemongrass-y, ginger-y, pepper-y
all at the same time,
but with a texture that's
similar to bamboo shoots.
(speaking in foreign language)
That's absolutely stunning.
The fresh fish, it just like,
dissolves in your mouth,
and yeah, I'm just
blown away by the rakam.
Next step for the fish, and
this is a pompano, I believe,
that she deep-fried,
and there's two different dipping sauces
that you can eat with it.
Some of the fish.
Oh, that flakes off beautifully.
(upbeat music)
(speaking in foreign language)
Sauce is just spectacular.
Again, the shrimp paste is so fragrant.
It has such that
well-rounded umami saltiness,
and then that rakam, that fruit,
that's just blowing me away
today in all of this food.
Mmm!
Mmm, mmm!
Yeah, that's different
from what I was expecting.
It's oil with chilis, a little
bit of fish sauce in there
and shallots.
And next up, for the plate of gai ga wan.
This is the stir-fried free-range chicken
with all of the cardamom stems in here,
and then, there all the
curry paste she added in,
and then some green peppercorns.
This looks spectacular.
(upbeat music)
Equally as much as the rakam,
the snake fruit is blowing my taste buds.
That krawan, those cardamom stems,
and you'll only find them
in this region of Thailand,
and they're truly spectacular.
It's something you have to eat.
And the actual mix of this
dish is called pad cha.
That mix of herbs and ingredients.
Mmm.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, I got some green
peppercorns in that bite.
It's so good, it's so good.
But that krawan, that stands out.
And finally, let me grab a
little piece of bitter melon,
raw bitter melon, and I'm going
straight for the nam prik.
When it's raw, the bitter melon,
it's crunchy like the
cucumber, or even crunchier,
but with that sensation
of bitterness, and then,
contrasted with that salty shrimp paste.
(upbeat music)
I'm loving that oil sauce too.
We've come to the end of the meal.
That was delicious.
I'm full, but I gotta have one
final bite of those noodles.
Oh, man.
I mean, it's almost sweet like dessert.
Well, that's why I wanted
it to be my final bite.
Those are like dessert noodles,
but the richness of that
coconut milk with the sourness
and the texture of those noodles,
that's what makes it so good.
(upbeat music)
(speaking in foreign language)
Oh, I'm in the ultimate
relaxed mood right now.
And this, this community, it's so cool.
This waterfront community.
We're gonna walk around the community
for just a little while now,
but they were saying that
there was an event yesterday.
It was kind of like a county
fair, and so it just finished,
and so a lot of the community that
normally would be selling
little snacks or things
are not doing that today because
they're resting from that event,
so I don't know if
there'll be much going on,
but we gotta just at least
take a look at the bridge again
and kind of walk through the community,
slowly.
(upbeat music)
(speaking in foreign language)
(motor humming)
(upbeat music)
(motorboat motor humming)
(birds chirping)
(speaking in foreign language)
There's not too much
going on in the village,
but it's so relaxing and
it's so peaceful like this.
But, there is an Auntie who
is slicing up pineapple,
pineapple from her garden,
and you can actually
smell the sweet juiciness.
You can smell it while
standing up and looking at it.
(motorbike motor humming)
Oh, mmm.
That's extraordinary pineapple.
Oh!
Oh, it's not mushy.
It's so sweet with a hint of tartness.
It's not stringy, it's silky smooth.
That's like, a perfect pineapple.
Yeah.
That is how pineapple should taste.
(upbeat music)
Definitely one of the highlights
of visiting Ban Nam Chiao
is that arch bridge.
It's impressive.
I mean, the arch shape, the
wooden planks that feel like
they might break at any
moment beneath your feet,
the low railing, you just
gotta love that bridge.
The ricketiness of it, it's
just oozing with character.
We're moving on out of the village,
and I didn't mention this to you
at the beginning of the day,
but we're actually on our
way to Koh Chang today,
which is the island,
one of the main popular islands
right off the coast of Trat.
Well, it's in Trat province,
and that's the plan for today.
We're going to Koh Chang, and
you can actually drive there
and you can take the ferry with your car.
Actually, this entire halal cooking
and visiting Ban Nam Chiao is
just kind of an extra thing
that I thought about, and I was like,
we have to come here before we leave.
And so, I'm glad I worked out.
This was fantastic, I
thoroughly enjoyed it.
(stammering) if you
have some time in Trat,
definitely, come hang
out at Ban Nam Chiao.
(upbeat music)
(car door slamming shut)
(motorbike motor humming)
(upbeat music)
- [Siri] Your destination
will be on the right.
- Just about a 30-minute drive.
We have arrived to the
Koh Chang ferry pier.
(speaking in foreign language)
They charge you by the car,
and then by the person.
Our total bill, was that 270 bhat?
- 280.
- 280, our total bill was 280,
and now we're lining up.
It doesn't look too busy today.
Think we're gonna get...
Either get right on, or
wait for the next ferry.
(upbeat music)
(key twisting)
Ah!
I can feel the sea breeze.
This is gonna be my first time, actually,
to ever visit Koh Chang,
and it's one of the most
popular islands in Thailand.
We're gonna do some relaxing
and some touring around,
and it's cool that we're
gonna be able to have
the car on the island.
This is the main upstairs
level, have plenty of seats.
(upbeat music)
That was about a 30-minute ride.
Welcome to Koh Chang.
(upbeat music)
(speaking in foreign language)
Oh, check out our elephant
towels. (chuckles)
Koh Chang means elephant island.
It's pretty cool, Michael loves it.
(door softly closing)
I think it was actually
about a 30-minute drive
from the ferry to get here,
but Koh Chang has really windy roads,
so you gotta wind around the mountain,
and you gotta make sharp turns,
but it's great to be here,
and I'm gonna end the
video for today right now.
We just plan to get a little...
just kind of walk around
today for the rest of the day,
but mainly, today was all
about visiting Ban Nam Chiao,
and then tomorrow, we'll
go on a tour of Koh Chang.
We're gonna visit some
of the famous sites,
and also eat some
delicious food, hopefully.
But that will be on the
next video upcoming.
So, thank you very much
for watching today's video.
Please remember to give it a
thumbs up if you enjoyed it,
and if you're not already
subscribed, click subscribe now,
and also click the little bell icon
so that you get notified
of the next video.
Goodbye from Koh Chang.
Thanks again for watching.
I'll see you on the next video.